je suis tombé un peu amoureux du script
en fait je suis tombé amoureux quand là
quand la la petite est arrivé dans
l'histoire parce que là ça quand même
cinq ans à changer les choses
vous dites là c'est assez étonnant
d'ailleurs parce que la petite qui
s'appelle nathalie portman coiffée à la
louise brooks étonnante de sensualité de
beauté de l'intelligence vous dites la
petite étape je parlais tout à l'heure
avant le début de l'émission et veut
dire ça me rappelait la petite la petite
de louis malle book shield oui et il y a
dans cette petite natalie portman des
dons absolument inouïe oui je crois que
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance comme enfin
voulez vous l'avez cherché
vous l'avez choisi bien cherché non mais
bon il ya ça fait partie des des
miracles comme ça on cherche on prend
évidemment la meilleure de toutes ces
jeunes filles mais avec quand même un
point d'interrogation
oui j'imagine est pas quand même quelle
qu'elles puissent aller aussi loin aussi
facilement c'est surtout ça qui m'a qui
m'a surpris il ya des scènes très très
dur qu'elle a joué évidemment puisque
les situations ne sont pas tout rose
c'est loin d'être le cas
comment on dirige une petite fille qui
avait 11 ans et demi je crois au moment
du tournage dans des situations
d'ultraviolence du le train des
rangements psychologique je dirais parce
que là il ya du cinéma mais il ya aussi
un être humain donc comment on fait pour
manipuler au bon sens du terme une
petite fille de 8 ans et demi dans des
situations comme ça je crois qu'il faut
être bien aller coûte
il faut bien parler avec les parents
aussi savoir où on va il ya plein de
choses qu'elle qu'elle fait mais qu'elle
ne sait pas l'art 11 ans et demi tout ce
qui est le rapport de séduction houleux
où cette espèce de d'amour naissant elle
en appelant n'avais pas notion du tout
donc elle elle a été amenée à faire des
choses qu'elle ne comprenait pas mais en
même temps au moment où il les faisait
comme bon à partir de 11 12 13 ans et
comme l'éveil l'éveil à
à la sensualité à la sexualité alors en
même temps ça la faisait ça l'avait
avancé en même temps donc c'était assez
assez périlleux on a essayé surtout de
la respecter l est et de la suivre mais
elle était très intelligent de comme je
vois grand le regard c'est que toutes
les scènes dures qui moi me mettais un
noeud au ventre parce que je me disais
si jamais elle ne peut pas la faire mais
je suis perdu je pourrais pas j'ai au
montage je serais perdue donc j'avais
vraiment un au ventre et à chaque scène
difficile genre scènes de pleurs de
déchirement de de vraiment les scènes
les plus durs il faisait ça d'abord elle
arrive et surexcité le matin il n'avait
qu'une envie de cesser de faire ça et
elle faisait deux prises trois prises et
puis ça y est c'est fini mais par contre
elle ne l est comme tous les enfants il
ya une autonomie elle avait 20 à 25
minutes d'autonomie au bout de 20
minutes faut arrêter ça faut la mettre
dehors
en dehors du plateau elle joue au
scrabble elle fait des réussites
elle dessine voilà vous la laissez dix
minutes un quart d'heure et elle revient
c'est impossible de là au bout de vingt
minutes elle décroche complètement ses
avions peuvent rien faire une petite
anecdote parce que enfin cet amusant
pour nous mais pas tellement pour jean
c'est que au début comme l avait jamais
fait de cinéma
elle n'avait pas du tout conscience du
chant et contre-chant donc ans était sur
elle elle était très concentré parce
qu'on lui demandait si j'étais j'étais
là mais le contrechamp sur gens et s'en
foutait complètement elle avait aucune
notion de don qu'elle el bayed mettait
le doigt dans le nez elle est le pauvre
jean avait vraiment beaucoup du mal au
début à jouer et elle le voyait pas donc
je disais mais reste là concentre toi un
petit peu mais ouais d'accord s
concentrait 10 secondes elle retombait
et un jour jean lui a juste pris la main
et lui dit tu sais c'est dur pour moi
aussi de l'autre côté et à la lcl appelé
conscience
elle a pris conscience d'un seul coup
qu'effectivement lui aussi c'était
c'était dur et âpre elle s'appliquait
était fausse d'ailleurs mais elle
s'appliquait au moins elle était si est
de donner un petit peu quoi
[Musique]